You could say a life without
risk is hardly worth having.
You know,
it might be secure.
Although it isn't because as I said,
not taking a risk also constitutes a risk.
And you know,
when you look back,
people often are more
upset about the things they didn't do,
the chances they didn't take then
the failures that they encountered.
Now,
not always,
obviously it depends on the failure,
but you know,
you can sit at home and Cayston Styrofoam
and have your meals delivered and
you're probably,
you know,
you're not going to get mugged probably.
But what's a hell of a life?
Psychologists have struggled for a long
time to define mental health and and
pathology.
It's really hard because mental
illness and even physical illness,
it's not simple.
It's not.
Sometimes it is,
there's a pathogen or not.
Even then it's complicated cause he
can't tell why the pathogen popped up at
that point.
But anyways,
in mental health it's even more difficult.
So you know,
people have tried to define what
constitutes optimal health or optimal
performance in a system or a person
in a bunch of different ways.
You can say,
well,
deviation from the
average is pathological,
but we don't think about that with
talent or beauty or intelligence.
So as a general principle,
that can't be right.
Um,
some people have said for mental health
that assist them is unhealthy when it
deviates from its evolutionary function.
Well I don't buy that because
it's very difficult to specify
the evolutionary function
of all sorts of things.
So that just doesn't
solve the problem for me.
What seems to happen as
far as I can tell is that
things are useful up to a certain point.
And once they dominate and sort of like
the cyclops image with the cyclops only
seeing one thing,
if you get to single
minded about anything,
any virtue or any
behavior for that matter,
it,
it hits a point where it
starts to turn back on itself.
And then you've gone too far.
And when it turns back on itself,
it hits him what's technically
called a positive feedback loop.
And then the things
spirals out of control,
catastrophic Lee and unpredictably.
And I can give you some examples of that.
So let's say you start to get depressed.
Okay.
And you know,
maybe you're slowly getting more and more
depressed while there's going to be a
tipping point or they're often as a
tipping point where you're so depressed,
you quit going to work
and you lose your job.
Well that's not so good for your
depression because now you're not only
depressed,
you're unemployed and
you don't have any money.
Well,
and then maybe your know your wife is
getting pretty tired of having to deal
with you because you're depressed and
now you also don't have a job and the
stress is too much for her.
And so you find a lot and
that makes you more depressed.
And then you start to stay at home
because you don't really want to show your
face in public.
So you lose all your friends and man,
it's a cliff.
So you're,
you're doing not too bad.
Even though it might be a downhill walk
until you hit this like single event and
then it just goes won't,
you know,
because being unemployed makes you more
depressed and that makes it more less
likely that you're going to
look for a job and you can okay.
With alcoholism what seems
and other forms of addiction,
what seems to happen to me is that you
hit the positive feedback loop point when
you start using the drug to cure
it's own withdrawal symptoms.
So you're not in trouble with cocaine
until you start using it because the
cocaine has made you feel bad.
And the withdrawal,
same with alcohol,
you're all shaky and you got the shakes
and so on and you figured out one day
Jesus shot of vodka.
I'm good.
Yeah,
no,
you're firmly in that grip of the devil.
And now at that point,
and I think a lot of
systems are like this,
they worked fine but,
but as they get more and more exaggerated,
they get closer and
closer to a tip off point.
And then the tip off point is where all
hell breaks loose and virtues or even
like that.
So we know,
for example,
that conscientiousness is a trait and
conscientious people are industrious and
orderly.
So it's like the Protestant work ethic.
Okay?
We also know that orderliness
is grounded in disgust.
Sensitivity.
Okay?
We know that orderly people on average
have better hygienic habits and they live
longer,
but they're also more,
uh,
inclined to radically disapproved
of homosexual behavior.
They're also more anti-foreigner because
they have a real tight me not mean
discrimination system,
and they're disgusted by what's not me.
Oh,
that's good.
You don't like dirt.
And you can be sure that
among our forefathers,
it was very frequent.
If you are an explorer and you went
out to meet a bunch of strangers,
you and your whole damn crew were dead
three weeks later because they gave you
some disease.
You have no resistance to whatsoever,
and it just wiped you out.
I mean,
that's what happened to the native
Americans and the White Dove,
95% of them,
you know,
it's it,
this is a deadly thing.
Anyways.
As orderliness increases in its intensity,
it starts to shade into
like vicious intolerance.
So the fascists,
for example,
the Nazis were orderly.
They didn't like parasites and they
thought of anything that wasn't just like
them.
They're corporate body.
The areas was a parasite and
it shouldn't be eradicated.
That's a pretty good idea when
you're eradicating parasites.
I mean,
Hitler tried to get rid of
tuberculosis to begin with,
but then the question arises,
what's a parasite?
At some point it's like
everyone who isn't meek,
you know,
hitting her got to that point before
he died because he felt that the whole
German society,
the lost faith in the air,
in society as the war was being lost and
he was perfectly happy that the bloody
place went up and fire,
which is a purifying element.
So,
you know,
even Lord,
conscientiousness is virtuous,
but you take any virtue
too far off the cliff,
you fall.
So,
so there's,
there's like this range
within which something works.
And when you push it past that range,
it starts to feed on itself.
And it turns into some variant of health.